Best Performance by an actor in a motion
picture Musical or Comedy Ryan Gosling
la-la-land good luck in the new year and
Ryan Reynolds for Deadpool cheer the
music they start drastically different
movies but in just under a month from
now Ryan Reynolds and Ryan Gosling will
go head-to-head at the Golden Globes so
how does Ryan Reynolds feel about this
stiff competition he joined me on the
phone right after his big announcement
you were Ryan Gosling her up against one
another well you were your character
reach out to him and do a little smack
talk
you can sing you a song you could put
the suit on something like that we can't
usually tell each other apart oh uh I
don't know I don't know if that's gonna
go down although I do love it when
people mistake me for Ryan Gosling
because I I'm very quietly in the back
of my mind whispers I wish I wait for
upgrade and when it comes to award shows
this nomination is an upgrade in itself
Ryan's never before been nominated for
one of the big three award shows
referring to the Golden Globes the
Oscars and the Emmys
Deadpool also scored a nomination for
Best Picture comedy or musical so how
are you and Blake going to celebrate the
this nomination tonight we're gonna go
out for a nice dinner I think it's a
graphic date night she and I and I owe
her that too because I was characterized
her of an invisible partner in this
whole thing she's been so helpful with
Deadpool and he's found so many ideas
off of her I owe her a big one so
tonight a minute a minute she's going to
cash in well Blake cashes in a dinner
Lana Lang cashes in at today's Globe
nomination the musical leads the pack
with seven noms in total including Best
Picture Musical or Comedy Best Director
and of course best actor and actress for
Ryan and Emma today Ryan Gosling
celebrates with a front and center cover
on this month's GQ magazine